-Come on, bud.
It's always good to see you.
I have lots of things
to talk to you about.
-First of all, let me thank you
for being so nice to my wife
-Your wife?
-when she was here.
-She was so funny.
-That's like one
of the best shows
I've ever seen you do.
[ Laughter ]
-It was.
It was good.
She was fantastic.
She was on fire, by the way.
Tell her to come back
whenever she wants.
-Yeah.
-She crushed. I love her.
-Thank you.
-And we'll talk about her
later on,
when we talk about the play.
-Okay.
-Now, I want to talk
about Nick Fury.
-Oh.
-Yes!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Fans are waiting.
I'm waiting.
Two new Marvel projects --
"The Marvels"
and "Secret Invasion."
Are you excited
to play him again?
-Always excited to, you know,
put that eyepatch on
or just hang out with some
of the people that I really,
really enjoy being
around when that's happening.
Like Brie is like amazing
and the whole new setup
with the Marvels,
the new family.
-You like getting in there.
I saw you just you made
an appearance
on "Sesame Street."
[ Laughter ]
Not the Avengers.
This is the...
-Aveggies.
-...Aveggies.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And these are
the Aveggies.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-Come on, bud.
That's why we love you.
Come on.
You do -- Come on,
that's cool, that you do that.
-A bucket list thing.
I've been trying to get
on "Sesame Street" for years.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
I've been after my publicist
and all my people like,
"When am I going
to get on 'Sesame Street'?"
And every time I see
somebody else on there, I go,
"How'd they get on there and I'm
[ Laughter ]
still not on 'Sesame Street'?"
-Yeah. I mean, well, I mean,
you've probably had
to watch your mouth a little bit
around the Muppets.
-Every now and then.
The word of the day couldn't be
my favorite word,
that's for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-I read this interesting fact
about you.
That, when you were
doing "Star Wars,"
that you used to carry
a lightsaber around
in your golf bag.
-Episode...III, yeah.
-So you could practice doing --
-Well, I had my practice
lightsaber.
Well, actually,
it was the lightsaber
that I actually used
to actually fight in the film
because you actually have like
a saber that has
like a plastic metal thing
that's covered in plastic.
So, it has all kinds
of nicks and --
-Really? For rehearsing?
-Yeah, from rehearsing.
But I had like a 93- to 98-move
thing to learn...
-Yeah.
-...going through three rooms,
mostly backwards, so...
-Yeah, I guess so, yeah.
-when I was --
had downtime in the tee box,
standing around,
I would just take it out
and go through my head
[ Laughter ]
like I was going through,
doing stuff,
but, you know,
and I would do it.
-Yeah. And people
were cool with that?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They're like,
"That's fun"?
-Yeah. Yeah.
The people I was playing with,
you know,
they knew what was happening,
so, it was alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Mace Windu's just going
for it, yeah.
-Yeah, man, just go in there,
doing my thing.
It's not simple.
-I have a --
-Oh, look out.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ah ah ah.
Y...eah.
-I have one for me, too.
I'm feeling that.
[ Humming ]
[ Whoosh ]
[ Oohs ]
Whoa!
-How'd you do that?
-I used the Force.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-You know something
I don't know.
-Can we dim the lights?
[ Laughter ]
-Boop it again.
-Yeah, can you boop it again?
-Boop!
[ Hissing, humming ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Alright, now. Ooh!
Now, what do we do?
Wow, that's good, right --
That feels cool there.
-But do they make clashing
sounds when they hit?
[ The Roots playing
suspenseful rock ]
[ Whooshing ]
-Oh, they do.
Mine does.
-Little bit.
[ Cheering and applause ]
This one does.
-[Indistinct]
[ Whooshing ]
[ Laughter ]
What you got?
What you got? What you got?
[ Cheering ]
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-[ Laughs ]
Come on.
-Now, will it just stay purple?
-Yeah, no, yeah, just stay on.
Here we go.
-Uh!
[ Whoosh ]
-Thank you. Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Getting that for Christmas.
-Thank you for doing it. I know.
-My pleasure. My pleasure.
-I can't wait. Thank you, buddy.
Can we talk about "The Piano
Lesson," please?
-Yes, please.
-This is at the
Barrymore Theatre.
-Ah!
-You're getting
rave reviews on this
and you're directed by your
very talented wife.
-My wife, LaTanya,
directed it, yes.
And we're having a measure
of success,
to the point that we've been
extended, now,
till January 29th!
-That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-So.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
So, if you're doing nothing
over the holidays,
come see the show or...
-Yeah.
-Christmas night.
We have a show Christmas night.
-You're working on Christmas?
-8:00 Christmas night.
-No way!
-Yeah.
-You really got to work
over there on Broadway, man.
-Mm-hmm.
-Can we say
what the play's about?
Can we we set it up?
-Wow.
It's a play --
"The Piano Lesson" is
about an heirloom piano that's
in the house in Pittsburgh
that Berniece, my niece,
cherishes.
It's a family heirloom.
And her brother, Boy Willie,
played by
John David Washington --
Danielle Brooks is Berniece.
John David Washington wants
to sell the piano
to acquire some land
in Mississippi
that will change his life
and keep him from going back
and forth through the, you know,
the prison system or whatever's
going on down there.
And she wants to keep it,
he wants to sell it, so,
that's the conundrum
of the play.
-Yeah. And you actually played
in this --
You were in this play --
-I was Boy Willie.
I was the original Boy Willie,
in the first production
at Yale, 30-some years ago.
[ Ohhs ]
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-And look at you now.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Now I get the rest.
-Now you work on Christmas, now.
[ Laughter ]
-I get the rest and do nothing.
But I do have one question
for you
before you kick me out of here.
If I get a bill from Elon Musk
for $8, can I send that to you,
since I joined Twitter
on this show?
[ Ohhs ]
-That's right, you did.
-Remember that.
My first tweet was on this show.
[ Laughter ]
-I will get you $8.
I promise I'll get you $8.
-$8 a month.
-Ooh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Right?
$8 a month, right?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-We're going to talk --
We'll talk to you --
I'll talk to Elon.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'll figure out something.
Samuel Jackson.
"The Piano Lesson" in playing
now through January 29th
at the Barrymore Theatre.
We're doing something fun
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on.